[Music]
many times I go around the world to
speak and people ask me questions about
the challenges
my movements
some of my regrets
1998 a
single mother for three months after the
birth of my fourth child I
went to do a job as a research assistant
went or not in Liberia and
as part of the work the village will
give you lodgings and they gave me
lodging with a single mother and her
daughter
this girl happened to be the only girl
in the entire village who had made it to
the ninth grade
she was the laughingstock of the
community her mother was often told by
other women you and your child will die
for
after two weeks of working in that
village it was time to go back
the mother came to me knelt down and
said Lima take my daughter I wish for
her to be a nurse
dirt pool living in the home with my
parents I couldn't a photo
with tears in my eyes I said no
two months later I go to another village
on the same assignment and it asked me
to live with the village chief
the woman's chief of the village has
this little girl fair color like me
totally dirty and all day she walked
around only in her underwear when I
asked who is that she says that's we the
meaning of her name is pink her mother
died while giving birth to her and no
one had any idea who her father was
for two weeks she became my companion
slept with me I bought her used clothes
and bought her her first doll the nights
before I left she came to the room and
said Lima don't leave me here I wish to
go with you I wish to go to school dirt
poor no money living with my parents I
again said no two months later both of
those villages fell into another war
till today I have no idea where those
two girls are
fast-forward
2004 in the peak of our activism the
minister of gender Liberia called me and
said we might have a nine year old for
you I want you to bring her home because
we don't have safe homes the story of
this new girl she had been raped by her
paternal grandfather every day for six
months she came to me bloated very pill
every night I come from working lie on
the cold floor she lies beside me and
say auntie I wish to be well I wish to
go to school
2010 or young woman stand before
President Sirleaf and give her testimony
of how she and her siblings live
together their father and mother died
during the war she's 19 her dream is to
go to college to be able to support them
she's highly athletic one of the things
that happens is that she applied for a
scholarships for scholarship she gets it
her dream of going to school how wish of
being educated is finally here she goes
to school on the first day the director
of sports who's responsible for getting
her into the program act her to come out
of class and for the next three years
her faith will be having sex with him
every day as favour forgetting her in
school
globally we have
policies
international instruments world leaders
great people have made commitment we
will protect our children from want and
from fear the UN has the Convention on
the Rights of the Child
countries like America we've heard
things like No Child Left Behind other
countries come with different things
there is a Millennium Development Goal
tree that focuses on girls all of these
great work by great people aimed at
getting young people to where we want to
get them globally I think has filmed in
Liberia for example teenage pregnancy
rate is 3 so every ten girls
teen prostitution is at its peak in one
community we told you wake up in the
morning and see used condoms like use
chewing gum paper girls as young as 12
being prostituted for less than a dollar
or night is this happening is sad and
then someone asks me just before my
tech-talk few days ago so where is the
hope several years ago few friends of
mine decided we needed to bridge the
disconnect between our generation and a
generation of young women is not enough
to say you have two Nobel laureates from
the Republic of Liberia when your girls
kids are totally out there and no hope
or seemingly no hope we created a space
called the young girl's transformative
project we go into rural communities and
all we do like has been done in this
room is create this space when these
girls sit
you unlock intelligence you unlock
passion you unlock commitment you unlock
focus you unlock great leaders today
we've worked with over 300 and some of
those girls who walked in the room very
shy have taken bold steps as young
mothers to go out there and advocate for
the rights of other young women one
young woman I met teen mother of four
never taught about finishing high school
graduated successfully never thought
about going to college enroll in college
one day she said to me my wishes to
finish college and be able to support my
children she's at a place where she
can't find money to go to school she
sells water sell soft drink and sell
recharge card for cell phones and you
would think she would take that money
and put it back into her education one
it is her name she takes that money and
find single mothers in her community to
send back to school says Lima my wish is
to be educated and if I can't be
educated when I see some of my sisters
being educated my wish has been
fulfilled I wish for a better life I
wish for food for my children I wish
that sexual abuse and exploitation in
schools will stop this is the dream of
the African girl several years ago there
was one African girl this girl had a son
who wish for a piece of donut because he
was extremely hungry
angry
frustrated
really upset about the state of her
society and the state of her children
this young girl started a movement a
movement of ordinary women banding
together to build peace I will fulfill
the wish this is another African girl's
wish I fail to fulfill the wish of those
two girls I fail to do this these were
the things that were going through the
head of this other young woman I failed
I failed I failed so I will do this
we may came out
protested a brutal detector
fearlessly spoke
not only did the wish of a piece of
donor come true the wish of peace came
true this young woman we also to go to
school she went to school this young
woman wish for other things to happen it
happened for her today this young woman
is me a Nobel laureate I'm now on a
journey to fulfill the wish in my tiny
capacity of little African girls a wish
I've been educated we set up a
foundation we're giving full four-year
scholarships to girls from villages that
we see with potential I don't have much
to acts of you I've also been to places
in this US and I know that girls in this
country also have wish wish for a better
life somewhere in the Bronx wish for a
better life somewhere in downtown LA
wish for a better life somewhere in
Texas wish for a better life somewhere
in New York wish for a better life
somewhere in New Jersey will you journey
with me to help that girl be at an
African girl or an American girl or a
Japanese girl fulfill her wish fulfilled
her dream achieved that dream because
all of these great innovators and
inventors that we've talked to and sing
over the last few days are also sitting
in tiny corners in different parts of
the world and all they're asking us to
do is create that space to unlock the
intelligence unlock the passion unlock
all of the great things that they hold
within themselves let's journey together
let's journey together thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much right now in Liberia
what do you see as the main issue that
troubles you
I've been asked to lead the Liberian
reconciliation initiative as part of my
work I'm doing these tours in different
villages and towns 1315 hours on dirt
roads and there is no community that
I've gone into
that I haven't seen intelligent girls
but sadly
the vision of a great future or the
dream of a great future is just a dream
because you have all of these vices teen
pregnancy like I said is epidemic so
what troubles me is that and I was at
that place and
somehow I'm at this place and I just
don't want to be the only one at this
place I'm looking for ways for other
girls to be with me I want to look back
20 years from now and see that there's
another Liberian girl Ghanaian girl
Nigerian girl it's European girl
standing on this stage and maybe just
maybe saying because of that Nobel
laureate I'm here today so I'm troubled
when I see them like there's no hope but
I'm also not pessimistic because I know
it doesn't take a lot to get them
charged up and in the last year tell us
one hopeful thing that you've seen
happening I can tell you many hopeful
things that I've seen happening but in
the last year where President Sirleaf
comes from her village we went there to
work with these girls and we could not
find 25 girls in high school all of
these girls went to the gold mine and
they were predominantly prostitutes
doing other things we took 50 of those
girls and we worked with them and this
was at the beginning of elections this
is one place where women were never even
the older ones barely sat in the circle
with the men these girls banded together
and form a group and launched a campaign
for voters registration this is a real
rule of the leash and the team they use
was even pretty girls would they were
able to mobilize young women but not
only they did do that they went to those
who were running for seats to ask them
what is it that you gave the girls of
this community when you win and one of
the guys who already had the seat was
very because Liberia has one of the
strongest rape law and he was one of
those really fighting in Parliament to
overturn that law because he called it
barbaric rape is not by Barry but the
law he said was my barrack and when the
girl started engaging him he was very
hostile towards them these little girls
turned to him and said we will watch you
out of office his out of office today
thank you thank you so much for coming
ahead thank you
[Applause]
[Music]